Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to this special edition of The Rest Is History. It's Sunday morning, the American presidential election has reached its climax, and last night, among considerable recrimination from Donald Trump, Joe Biden was declared the 46th President of the United States of America. It was an election for the very soul of modern America, with Trump fighting tooth and nail to cling on to power. So is this unheard of? Who
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》特别版。现在是周日早晨，美国总统大选已经进入高潮，就在昨晚，在唐纳德·特朗普的一片激烈指责声中，乔·拜登被宣布当选美利坚合众国第46任总统。这是一场关乎现代美国灵魂的选举，特朗普为了死死抓住权力进行了拼死抵抗。那么，这难道是前所未闻的吗？是谁
does Trump think he is? Is he a modern-day Julius Caesar or an updated and slightly shop-soiled Richard Nixon, ancient or modern? Well, the joke is, of course, that Trump brought the news that Biden had been elected while he was on the Gulf Corps. So there have been lots of comments about dictators being cornered in bunkers. The Hitler parallel has been much aired, but isn't one, I think, Dominic, that you would have much time for? Probably not. The jokesmith who's just spoken is, of my sparring partner Tom Holland. The Trump-Hitler analogy, my goodness, that's a well-worn analogy and one for which I have absolutely no time at all. Actually, one thing that Trump and Hitler had in common, two things they had in common, Tom, they're both very funny about their food. So Hitler, of course, was a vegetarian and
特朗普把自己当成什么人了？他是当代的尤利乌斯·凯查，还是一个升级版、稍微有点过时的理查德·尼克松？是古代还是现代？当然，好笑的是，特朗普得知拜登当选的消息时，他正在打高尔夫球。所以有很多关于独裁者被逼入地堡的评论。关于希特勒的类比被广泛讨论，但这并不是一个我认为你会有兴趣的类比，多米尼克？可能没有。刚刚说话的这位段子手，是我的辩论搭档汤姆·霍兰。特朗普与希特勒的类比，天哪，这是一个老生常谈的类比，我绝对没空去理会。事实上，特朗普和希特勒有一个共同点，准确地说是两个共同点，汤姆，他们在饮食上都非常滑稽。所以希特勒，当然，他是个素食主义者，而
Trump only eats McDonald's burgers. And they're both very lazy. So Hitler didn't get up until kind of midday and didn't do any work. And I don't think Donald Trump's work ethic has ever really... And was Hitler teetotal? Yes, he was. So... So Trump is as well. So there's a third comparison. Is Trump teetotal? So they're stacking up.
特朗普只吃麦当劳汉堡。而且他们都很懒。希特勒直到中午左右才起床，什么也不干。而且我认为唐纳德·特朗普的工作伦理从来没有真正……希特勒是不喝酒的吗？是的，他是。所以……所以特朗普也是。所以这是第三个比较。特朗普也不喝酒吗？所以这些相似之处正在累积。
Yes. Hitler was less orange. Hitler was less orange. No doubt about that. And not into golf, as far as I know. Okay. Okay. So I think that we're really pushing the boundaries of historical inquiry here. We are. But Dominic, actually, talking of historical inquiry, I'm right, aren't I, that Nixon was a particular area of specialisation for you. That's kind of the area you did your doctorate in. Well, I did my doctorate in sort of late 60s American politics, and that's Richard Nixon's time. So the election of 1968, that's when Nixon, running as a law and order candidate, carried all before him, and he became US president.
是的。希特勒没那么橘。希特勒没那么橘。毫无疑问。据我所知，他也不喜欢打高尔夫球。好吧。好吧。所以我觉得我们在这里真的是在挑战历史探究的边界。确实如此。但是，多米尼克，事实上，说到历史探究，我没说错吧，尼克松是你的一个特别专长领域。那算是你攻读博士学位的领域。嗯，我研究的博士方向是60年代末的美国政治，那正是理查德·尼克松的时代。所以1968年的大选，那是尼克松作为法律与秩序候选人参选并横扫一切、最终成为美国总统的时候。
And I used to teach a course that lasted all year about Richard Nixon. It was my special subject course, and it was brilliant. We kind of got into Nixon's head. We started with his love letters to Pat, his wife, and we ended with him basically being winched out of the White House, kicking and screaming. And that, of course, is the parallel because, you know,
我过去曾教过一门持续一整年的关于理查德·尼克松的课程。这是我的专题课程，非常棒。我们某种程度上走入了尼克松的内心世界。我们从他对妻子帕特的情书开始，到他基本上被用绞盘从白宫里拖出来、又踢又叫结束。当然，这就是相似之处，因为你知道的，
he's the only analogy I can think of, of somebody leaving the White House with this sort of air of shambolic indignity that we have right now with Mr Trump. And Nixon, of course, did not lose an election. No, he's an election winner. Massive winner. Election winner. So he essentially has to resign. Did he fight to stay in the White House as furiously as Trump is currently fighting? Yes, I suppose he did. So it's an extraordinary story, the Nixon story. It's much more complicated than Trump's story, because Nixon won the 1972 presidential election in a stonking landslide. So there's a big contrast there with Trump. Nixon won every single state except Massachusetts and
他是我想到的唯一一个带着这种凌乱而屈辱的气息离开白宫的人，就像我们现在在特朗普先生身上看到的那样。当然，尼克松并没有输掉选举。不，他是选举的赢家。大赢家。选举赢家。所以他基本上不得不辞职。他像特朗普现在这样拼命挣扎着留在白宫吗？对，我想他确实如此。所以这是一个非同寻常的故事，尼克松的故事。它比特朗普的故事要复杂得多，因为尼克松在1972年的总统大选中以压倒性优势获胜。所以这与特朗普形成了巨大的反对比。尼克松赢得了除马萨诸塞州和
the District of Columbia. So this sort of utter wipeout of the Democrats. But Nixon's gnawing insecurity was such that he had got his team effectively to bug the Democrats. He colluded and then he covered it up and then he covered up the cover up. And so you had this unfolding scandal for the next sort of 18 months or so. And when it turned out that Nixon had been taping himself and his sort of dirty secrets were aired before the American public, he had to go. But of course, as politicians always do, he fought and he he you know he he sort of tried everything he tried to spin things and eventually in august 1974 he the republican senators told him you know time's up and he had to go but where i think the parallel works is that you know nixon left in the
哥伦比亚特区之外的所有州。所以这是对民主党人的一种彻底摧毁。但尼克松挥之不去的极度不安全感，使他甚至让自己的团队去窃听民主党人。他合谋然后掩盖，接着又掩盖这个掩盖。所以在接下来的大约18个月里，这桩丑闻不断发酵。当事实证明尼克松一直在录音，他那些肮脏的秘密在公众面前曝光时，他不得不下台。当然，正如政客们一贯的做法那样，他进行了抗争，他你知道的，他尝试了一切方法，他试图粉饰太平，最终在1974年8月，共和党参议员告诉他，你知道的，时间到了，他必须离开。但我认为相似之处在于，你知道，尼克松离开时的姿态是
most undignified way possible so he gave a fairly standard resignation speech to the nation. But when it came to the day of his departure, so the morning of his departure, he stayed up all night sort of sweating and staring into the shadows. And then and he's knackered and he's overwrought and he's a bit of a bit of a mess. And he gives this extraordinary farewell speech to his staff, which is televised. And anyone, the listeners who've seen the Anthony Hopkins film, Nixon, will probably remember this. And he just completely disintegrates on camera. He's talking about his dad, who was a little guy and a common man. He says his mother was a saint. He basically starts crying when he talks about his mother. And it's just this awful disintegration and flies completely in the face of everything
极其不尊严的。他向全国发表了一篇相当标准辞职演讲。但到了他离开的那天，也就是离开的早晨，他整晚没睡，一直在流汗，凝视着阴影。然后他筋疲力尽，情绪激动，成了一团乱麻。他向工作人员发表了一场非同寻常的告别演讲，这是通过电视直播的。看过安东尼·霍普金斯主演的电影《尼克松》的听众可能还记得这一点。他在镜头前彻底崩溃了。他谈到了他的父亲，一个普通的小人物，他说他的母亲是个圣人。当他谈到母亲时，他基本上开始哭泣。这真是一次可怕的崩溃，完全违背了所有
Americans expect from their president, which is a level of dignity and civility and sort of sobriety and all the rest of it. And it's sort of gone down as the acme of what not to do, how not to leave the White House. Yeah, and that's interesting because, I mean, one of the things, of course, that Trump's behaviour raises is the question of why do people find it so shocking? And why did people find Nixon's behaviour so shocking? And it suggests that there is a kind of very strong, often unwritten code about how Americans expect their politicians and particularly their leaders to behave. And of course, this so often goes against the reality, because I guess to reach the top of American politics, you have to play hard and dirty. But there is a kind of
美国人对他们总统的期望，那就是一种尊严、礼貌、清醒等等。这可以说是如何不要做事、如何不要离开白宫的巅峰反面典型。是的，这很有意思，因为我的意思是，特朗普的行为引发的一个问题是，为什么人们会觉得如此震惊？为什么人们会觉得尼克松的行为如此震惊？这表明，关于美国人期望他们的政客，尤其是他们的领导人应该如何行事，存在着一种非常强烈、通常不成文的行为准则。当然，这往往与现实背道而驰，因为我想为了登上美国政治的顶峰，你必须手段强硬且肮脏。但同时，
always this sense that, you know, there are moral standards that you have to live up to. And if, as Trump's currently doing, and as Nixon did, you break that, then people are genuinely shocked. Yeah, I think that's right, actually. I mean, they do fight hard. But actually, when you look back at American politics, the striking thing is how often they do feel the need to conform to these codes. So Al Gore, when he lost the presidency to George Bush, George W. Bush in 2000, in kind of dubious circumstances, he... Ah! Oh, that's a gift to you, Tom. I'll never speak again in this podcast. He gives them all away. It does. Yeah, terrible, terrible.
总有一种感觉，你知道的，有一些你必须遵守的道德标准。如果像特朗普现在做的那样，以及尼克松曾经做的那样，你打破了这一点，那么人们就会感到真正的震惊。是的，我想这确实没错。我的意思是，他们的确斗争得很激烈。但事实上，当你回顾美国政治时，最引人注目的是他们是多么频繁地觉得有必要遵守这些准则。所以阿尔·戈尔，当他在2000年把总统宝座输给乔治·布什、乔治·W·布什时，在某种可疑的情况下，他……啊！哦，这真是送分题，汤姆。我以后在这档播客里再也不说话了。你把所有的底牌都交出去了。确实。是的，太糟糕了，太糟糕了。
He loses possession. It's a schoolboy error. Yeah, it is Roman. It is Roman. I'm so glad you brought that up. Because, of course, the question of the code, the code of honour. Yeah.
他失控了。这是一个初学者的错误。是的，罗马的错误。这就是罗马。我很高兴你提到了这一点。因为当然，关于准则的问题，荣誉准则。是的。
I mean, it goes back, ultimately, to the, I guess, to the example of Washington. It does. I'm glad you brought it back to American politics, Tom, and left the Romans honour. Yeah. I mean, it goes back ultimately to the, I guess, to the example of Washington. It does. I'm glad you brought it back to American politics, Tom, and left the Romans behind. Yeah. Well, well, wait, wait, because Washington is a general. He's a victorious general who has thrown out a king and who has laboured to establish a republic. Yes. And so the big, the big question is, you know, is he going to lay down his sword? Is he going to return to his farm? And it so happens that the American founding fathers, who are absolutely steeped in the study of ancient Roman history, have the model of the Roman Republic to hand because the Roman
我的意思是，归根结底，这要追溯到，我想，华盛顿的榜样。确实如此。我很高兴你把它拉回到了美国政治，汤姆，把罗马人抛在脑后。是的。我的意思是，归根结底，这要追溯到，我想，华盛顿的榜样。确实如此。我很高兴你把它拉回到了美国政治，汤姆，把罗马人抛在脑后。是的。好吧，好吧，等等，等等，因为华盛顿是一名将军。他是一位 victorious 的将军，他赶走了国王，并努力建立了一个共和国。是的。所以，最大的问题是，你知道，他会放下他的剑吗？他会回到他的农场吗？碰巧的是，那些绝对沉浸在古罗马历史研究中的美国开国元勋们，手头正好有罗马共和国的模版，因为罗马
Republic is established after a king is expelled. And it works because it establishes this code, the Mossmaioran they call them, the kind of the customs held to by the ancestors that everyone is expected to hold to and that's what the founding fathers are kind of looking to and that's the model that Washington is drawing on. Exactly, so the Washington story is a good one. So he basically gives up his command in 1783, the Continental Army has won, or rather the French have won the war for them. Britain has basically given up. America has its independence. And actually, there's then a six-year break before Washington actually becomes president. So he doesn't actually become president until 1789. And basically, they have to drag him
共和国是在驱逐国王后建立的。它之所以能运转，是因为它确立了这样一种准则，他们称之为“祖宗成法”（Moss maiorum），也就是每个人都被期望遵守的祖先传下来的习俗，这就是开国元勋们所期待的，也是华盛顿所借鉴的模版。没错，所以华盛顿的故事是一个很好的故事。他基本上在1783年放弃了指挥权，大陆军已经获胜，或者更准确地说，法国人替他们赢得了战争。英国人基本上放弃了。美国获得了独立。事实上，随后有六年的间歇期，华盛顿才真正成为总统。所以他直到1789年才真正成为总统。基本上，他们不得不连踢带打地
kicking and screaming into the job. He doesn't really want to do it. They turn to him because he's a unifying figure, because he's a patriotic figure and all the rest of it. But he doesn't really fancy it. And then after his first term, again, he doesn't really want to carry on. And they basically compel him. The other founding fathers say, no, no, you must stay and do it. And then he leaves after his second term and establishes this tradition, which only one president, FDR, in the Second World War,
把他拉进这个职位。他其实并不想干。他们转向他是因为他是一个团结的 figura（人物），因为他是一个爱国的人物等等。但他其实并不太想干。然后在他的第一个任期结束后，同样地，他其实不想继续下去了。其他开国元勋基本上强迫了他。他们说，不，不，你必须留下来干。然后在他的第二个任期结束后，他确立了这个传统——只有罗斯福在第二次世界大战期间打破过这一传统——
has ever broken, that a president will only do two terms. So that sort of, I'm hesitant to give you the ball back so easily, but that sort of ethos of the reluctant leader who has to be sort of coerced into the job, I mean, he's obviously trying to live up, I mean, he was the president of a group called the Society of the Cincinnati. And there you have your Roman hero, Cincinnatus, that I'm sure you're about to tell us about. I certainly am. So Cincinnatus is absolutely the archetype for this, who is a legendary figure from the early years of the Roman Republic. And the reason that he serves as such an iconic figure, both for the Romans and then for the Americans, is that he's a great war leader who is also a farmer and he is summoned from his plough to save his people, to lead his country.
即总统只能担任两届。所以，我有点犹豫要不要这么轻易地把球传回给你，但这种不情愿的领导者的精神气质，他不得不被某种程度上胁迫着去担任这个职务——我的意思是，他显然是在努力不负这种期望，他曾是一个叫做“辛辛那提学会”的组织的总统。这里就提到了你的罗马英雄辛辛那提，我确信你接下来就要跟我们讲讲他了。我当然要讲。所以辛辛那提绝对是这方面的原型，他是罗马共和国早期的一位传奇人物。他之所以能成为这样一个标志性人物，对罗马人和后来的美国人都如此重要，是因为他是一位伟大的战争领袖，同时也是一个农夫，他从犁沟中被召唤出来拯救他的国家，领导他的国家。
And then having saved his country, he then returns to the plough. And this is such a kind of perfect image for Washington. There's a sensational statue, I think it's in the Smithsonian by Horatio Greenough, which obviously this is a podcast, unfortunately I can't bring it up for you. But anyone, Google it. It's so brilliant. It's Washington with his wig in a toga holding a sword. And it perfectly illustrates this kind of strange 18th century Roman fusion that the American, early American Republic kind of absolutely plays with. So those early Americans, I mean, they basically thought they were the Romans, didn't they? But particular kind of Romans, right? Because obviously there's lots of, they have this, do they have this idealised image of
然后在拯救了国家之后，他又回到了犁地。这对于华盛顿来说是一个如此完美的意象。史密森尼学会里有一尊轰动一时的雕像，我想那是霍拉蒂奥·格里诺（Horatio Greenough）的作品，显然这是一档播客，不幸的是我无法把它展示给你们。但是任何人，去谷歌一下。太棒了。那是华盛顿，戴着假发，穿着托加长袍，手持宝剑。它完美地阐释了早期美国共和国绝对在玩味的这种奇怪的18世纪罗马融合。所以早期的美国人，我的意思是，他们基本上认为自己就是罗马人，不是吗？但那是特定的一种罗马人，对吧？因为很显然，他们有这种，他们有对
Rome, do you think? I mean, obviously most Romans are probably just like us. Yes, they're haunted by the fact that, of course, the early days of the Republic, when everyone is virtuous and kind of yeoman farmers and at their plough, that the Roman Republic expands, it becomes incredibly wealthy, it becomes a superpower, it establishes its rule across the whole of the Mediterranean. And this then provides opportunities for ambitious Roman politicians to put the entire republic in its shadow. And in due course, that results in the establishment of an autocracy. And so every founding father is nervously aware of this. And so Benjamin Franklin, when he comes, he says, you know, is it going to be a republic?
罗马的这种理想化形象吗？我的意思是，显然大多数罗马人可能和我们一样。是的，他们被这样一个事实所困扰，即罗马共和国的早期，当每个人都充满美德、像自耕农一样安于农耕时，罗马共和国随之扩张了，变得极其富有，成了一个超级大国，将其统治确立到了整个地中海。这随后为野心勃勃的罗马政客提供了把整个共和国置于其阴影之下的机会。假以时日，这就导致了专制政体的建立。因此，每一位开国元勋都神经质地意识到了这一点。所以本杰明·富兰克林，当他走过来时，他说，你知道，这会是一个共和国吗？
And he says, yeah, it's going to be a republic if we can keep hold of it. And that anxiety is always, and I guess it's because, you know, Nixon is very keen on the idea of America as an imperial republic. And so that's part of the shadow, I would guess, is it, of what's going on with Watergate and people's anxiety about him? Yeah, people talked about the imperial presidency. You're absolutely right. So obviously what had happened, I mean, basically until the 20th century, you know, America was kind of happening. But as far as the rest of the world was concerned, it was somewhere else who cared about them, let them get on with it. But then the 20th century, America does become an empire. I mean, there's people argue about this, but there's
他说，是的，如果我们能守住它，它就是一个共和国。这种焦虑始终存在，我想这是因为，你知道，尼克松非常热衷于将美国视为一个帝国共和国。所以我想这也是水门事件以及人们对他感到焦虑的阴影的一部分吧？是的，人们谈论过帝王般的总统制。你完全说得对。所以显然发生的事情是，我的意思是，基本上直到20世纪，你知道，美国一直在发展。但就世界其他地方而言，它是另一个地方，谁在乎他们呢，让他们自生自灭吧。但到了20世纪，美国确实变成了一个帝国。我的意思是，虽然人们对此有争论，但毫无疑问的是，
no doubt really, it has colonies, it has overseas bases, it has influence, it wins wars in foreign countries. And the people talk about the president as an American Caesar, they use that sort of terminology. And Nixon, so the presidencies of LBJ, Lyndon Johnson, who preceded Nixon, who's famous for Vietnam, and then Nixon, who ends the Vietnam War, that's kind of the high point of what people think of as the imperial presidency of a president that can do what he wants, and then Nixon, who ends the Vietnam War, that's kind of the high point of what people think of as the imperial presidency. Of a president that can do what he wants, he can evade who he wants, he's accumulating more and more power. And in certainly Nixon's case, he's using people like the FBI to, you know, survey his opponents, to bug his opponents. There's this sort of fear, which now seems completely hysterical but at the time was very
它确实拥有殖民地，拥有海外基地，拥有影响力，在外国打赢了战争。人们把总统称为“美式凯撒”，他们使用这种术语。尼克松——所以林登·约翰逊（LBJ）的总统任期，这位因越南战争而闻名、紧接着是尼克松的前任，以及结束了越战的尼克松——这正是人们所认为的“帝王般的总统制”的巅峰时期，即一个总统可以为所欲为，尼克松结束了越战，这正是人们所认为的“帝王般的总统制”的巅峰。一个可以为所欲为的总统，他可以躲避任何他想躲避的人，他正在积累越来越多的权力。在尼克松的例子中，他无疑在使用像联邦调查局这样的人去监视他的对手，去窃听他的对手。这种恐惧在当时看来完全是歇斯底里的，但在20世纪70年代初却非常
real in the early 1970s that you know under Nixon America was turning into a sort of police state and actually that's not so different from what we've heard in the last four years from Donald Trump's critics who believe that he represents the end of the republican dream right and again I think that that is that that's been an anxiety that has shadowed the american republic pretty much from the beginning i mean basically if you model yourself on on rome if you have a capital if you have a senate if your capital city has loads of columns and pillars that look like ancient rome then there are two things that are going to worry you the first is that if you're a a republic that
真实，你知道，在尼克松的统治下，美国正在变成一个警察国家。实际上，这与我们在过去四年里从唐纳德·特朗普的批评者那里听到的并没有太大不同，他们认为特朗普代表了共和之梦的终结。没错，而且我认为，这也是一种一直笼罩着美国共和国的焦虑，几乎从一开始就是这样。我的意思是，基本上，如果你以罗马为模版，如果你有一个国会山，如果你有一个参议院，如果你的首都拥有大量看起来像古罗马的圆柱和石柱，那么有两件事会让你担忧。第一件事是，如果你是一个共和国，
essentially the republic is going to collapse and that a caesar is going to emerge in augustus and the second one is that the entire you know rome the roman empire fell and so the american empire will fall yeah and i think that those those that's a kind of although the hitler you know trump is hitler has been very very kind kind of popular theme over the past four years. I think the Trump as a kind of Caesar has also been pretty popular. I know I've made a lot of good money writing far-fetched comparisons between Trump and Nero and so on. People often talk about the drawbacks of the Trump presidency, but they don't mention this one, which is the greatest, which is the immense amount of money you've made out of it. Well, not immense amount of money. I mean, scratching together the odd penny. But I think that that is a kind of, it's been there right from, say, Andrew Jackson.
本质上共和国将会崩溃，一个凯撒将会作为屋大维崛起；第二件事是，整个你知道的，罗马，罗马帝国灭亡了，所以美式帝国也将灭亡。是的，我认为这些——这是一个——尽管“特朗普是希特勒”在过去四年里一直是一个非常非常受欢迎的主题，但我认为“特朗普作为某种凯撒”也相当受欢迎。我知道我通过写一些关于特朗普与尼禄等人之间牵强附会的比较赚了不少好钱。人们经常谈论特朗普总统任期的缺点，但他们没有提到这一个，也就是最大的一个，即你从中赚取了巨额财富。好吧，并不是巨额财富。我的意思是，勉强凑齐零星半点。但我觉得这是一种，从安德鲁·杰克逊时代起就一直存在的东西。
Yeah. He was a general, a successful general. 1812 war general. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. People start thinking that he's going to be a Caesar. And I think that essentially, if you model yourself on Rome, the idea that you're going to decline and fall is kind of hardwired into your mind. But isn't it odd, Tom, that they keep electing generals, which is kind of a Roman thing in itself. So Andrew Jackson is a general, Ulysses Grant after the Civil War. And then even after World War Two, they go for Eisenhower, you know, the architect of D-Day. Although what's interesting with Biden, who, like every other man of his generation, president of his generation, did not serve in Vietnam. Actually, the key fact about
是的。他是一位将军，一位成功的将军。1812年战争的将军。是的。人们开始认为他会成为一个凯撒。我认为本质上，如果你以罗马为模版，那种你将会衰落和灭亡的想法已经深深烙印在你的脑海中了。但汤姆，这不是很奇怪吗，他们不断地选举将军，这本身就是一种很罗马的做法。所以安德鲁·杰克逊是一位将军，内战后的尤利西斯·格兰特也是。甚至在二战之后，他们还选择了艾森豪威尔，诺曼底登陆的策划者。尽管有趣的是，拜登和他的同龄人一样，他那个时代没有一位总统在越南服役。事实上，关键的事实是
recent presidents is that they didn't serve in the military. Yeah, that's true. It's a kind of interesting... And the one who did famously fail to win, John McCain. So John McCain was actually an extraordinarily Roman figure, isn't he? I mean, he's like somebody who's basically decided to role play his entire life. Yes. As a Roman war hero. Yes, yes. Because he fights for his country. He gets captured and brutally tortured and refuses to give in.
最近的几位总统都没有从军经历。是的，确实如此。这挺有意思的……而那个唯一参军且因参选总统而闻名遐迩却没有成功的人就是约翰·麦凯恩。所以约翰·麦凯恩实际上是一个非常具有罗马风范的人物，对吧？我的意思是，他就像是一个基本上决定把自己的整个人生都用来角色扮演的人。是的。扮演一个罗马战争英雄。是的，是的。因为他为国家而战。他被俘虏并遭受残酷折磨，但拒绝屈服。
And that, again, is absolutely redolent of figures from Roman history. There's this guy Regulus, who leads a campaign against the Carthaginians in the First Punic War, gets captured, gets sent back to Rome on the proviso that he will sue for terms and encourage the Senate to basically to surrender to Carthage. Regulus gets back to Rome, refuses to encourage the Senate to surrender, says no, carry on fighting, and then feels honour bound to return to Carthage, where he gets put in a barrel that has spikes driven through it, and he gets rolled down a hill. Wow. And does that kill him? Yes, it does kill him. I mean, that's, of course, McCain survives. But, you know, he kind of goes
而这再次绝对让人联想到罗马历史上的那些人物。有这么一个人叫雷古鲁斯，他在第一次布匿战争中领导了一场针对迦太基人的战役，被俘虏了，然后被送回罗马，前提条件是他要游说议会并鼓励元老院基本上向迦太基投降。雷古鲁斯回到罗马后，拒绝鼓励元老院投降，说不，继续打下去，然后他觉得出于荣誉必须返回迦太基，在那里他被塞进一个钉满尖刺的木桶里，然后从山坡上滚下去。哇。那这害死了他吗？是的，这确实害死了他。我的意思是，当然，麦凯恩活了下来。但是，你知道，他经历的
through torture for America in pretty much the same way. And in a way, one of the most kind of shocking things that Trump said, and kind of darkly funny, was he said, I don't like losers. I don't like my war heroes who get captured. Completely shocking. I've never met Regulus, but I did meet John McCain. Did you?
为了美国遭受的折磨方式其实差不多。从某种意义上说，特朗普说过的话中最让人震惊也最带有一点黑色幽默的一点是，他说，我不喜欢失败者。我不喜欢那些被俘虏的战争英雄。这完全令人震惊。我从来没见过雷古鲁斯，但我确实见过约翰·麦凯恩。你见过吗？
What was he like then? Shook hands with him. In a sort of depressing way, in that people sometimes are, he was exactly as he appeared to be on TV. So I have no colourful, you know, he didn't say, there's a great, you know, let's go and watch Call the Midwife, or...
他当时是什么样的人？和他握过手。以一种有点扫兴的方式，就像人们有时那样，他跟他在电视上看起来一模一样。所以我没有什么丰富多彩的，你知道的，他没有说，有一个很棒的，你知道的，我们去看《呼叫助产士》吧，或者……
No, he didn't. There was no hidden... Let's go and wrestle on the campus marshes. No, yes, exactly. No, I think we just passed the time of day. To be fair, I was part of a crowd. He was working his way down the line and I was in the line. I was in the crowd.
不，他没有。没有什么隐藏的……我们去战神广场摔跤吧。不，是的，完全没有。不，我想我们只是打发了一下时间。公平地说，我是人群中的一员。他当时正顺着队伍往前走，而我在队伍里。我在人群中。
I was observing the New Hampshire primary in 2000 when I was a graduate student and met all these candidates. Guys, this is the podcast that brings you brushes with the great man of history. Well, on that note, I think we should, Tom, I believe we have to count some mail-in ballots. So let's go and count our ballots. And in the meantime, let's take a short break and we'll be back in a minute.
2000年我读研究生时正在观察新罕布什尔州初选，当时见到了所有这些候选人。伙计们，这就是那个带你与历史伟人擦肩而过的播客。好吧，说到这里，汤姆，我想我们得统计一些邮寄选票了。所以我们去统计我们的选票吧。与此同时，我们休息一小会儿，一会儿就回来。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, We'll be back in a minute. head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. If you've enjoyed these first three or four episodes, please do subscribe and leave us a review and a rating on Apple Podcasts. And if you didn't enjoy them, well, please don't. And do get in touch using my Twitter handle,
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐而已》。这是你们获取娱乐新闻的每周固定节目，我们一会儿就回，请登录 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史而已》。如果你喜欢前三四集，请务必订阅，并在苹果播客上给我们留下评论和评分。如果你不喜欢，好吧，请别订阅。也请通过我的推特账号与我联系，
at DCSanbrookok or use tom's at holland underscore tom just realize tom that could be your uh cricketing epitaph underscore oh very amusing yeah i don't i don't actually write these links so you know you can blame the producer for that i'm completely blaming the producer for that and and so unfair the link have you ever sensational summer's a sensational summer. Do you not notice, Tom, that with these links, there's always a danger of turning into Alan Partridge, isn't there? Do you not think?
即 DCSanbrookok，或者使用汤姆的账号 holland underscore tom。汤姆，我刚意识到那可能可以当做你的板球墓志铭 underscore 哦，太逗了，是的，我其实不写这些链接，所以你知道的，你可以把这怪到制作人头上，我完全把这怪到制作人头上，这太不公平了，这个链接，你有没有经历过耸人听闻的夏天，一个耸人听闻的夏天。汤姆，你难道没有注意到，这些链接总是有变成阿兰·帕特里奇的危险吗？你不觉得吗？
I kind of feel Alan Partridge's ghost on my shoulder the whole time. Well, Alan Partridge was a commentator, not a player. And I am a player, so I don't feel the danger. I think it's all danger. Very good. And talking of being a player, talking of being a player, we were on the subject of John McCain. And there was a particularly Roman moment, I thought, and kind of interesting for the light to shed on the way that Roman politics perhaps holds a mirror up to contemporary American politics, which was his funeral.
我总觉得阿兰·帕特里奇的幽灵一直盘旋在我肩头。好吧，阿兰·帕特里奇是个评论员，而不是球员。而我是一个球员，所以我不觉得有什么危险。我认为到处都是危险。非常好。说到当球员，说到当球员，我们刚才在聊约翰尼·麦凯恩的话题。我当时觉得有一个特别具有罗马色彩的时刻，而且对于照亮罗马政治如何可能为当代美国政治提供一面镜子这一点很有趣，那就是他的葬礼。
And what happened at his funeral was that you had Democrats as well as Republicans going to it. Yes. And traditionally in Rome, funerals, the famous example is the funeral of Caesar, were great political order, people who held to the Mos Maiorum, the customs of the ancestors, were gathering there to honour a great American hero and to tell Trump that he was not part of the club. And the reason I think that that is particularly interesting from the Roman context is that it reflects the way in which Roman politics was organised, which was essentially not about policy. It wasn't kind of left or right. It was more about style. It was about whether you upheld the traditional values of the elite
在他的葬礼上发生的事情是，民主党人和共和党人都去参加了。是的。按照罗马的传统，葬礼——著名的例子是凯撒的葬礼——是一场伟大的政治秩序展示，那些坚守“祖先之风”（Mos Maiorum）即祖先习俗的人们聚集在那里，向一位伟大的美国英雄致敬，并告诉特朗普他不是俱乐部的一员。我认为从罗马的背景来看这特别有趣的原因是，它反映了罗马政治组织的方式，其本质上不是关于政策的。它不是什么左翼或右翼。它更多的是关于风格。它是关于你是否坚持精英阶层的传统价值观
or whether you kind of took the piss out of them. But you know what, Tom? That's very American. So both the presidents that we've really talked about, Trump and actually Nixon, they projected themselves as the champion of the common man, the ordinary American, the square, sort of square-jawed, square-dealing, the little guy. Nixon talks himself a lot about the little guy against the sneering snobs on Wall Street and in New York and in New England and all the rest of
还是你有点在取笑他们。但你知道吗，汤姆？这非常美国化。所以我们真正谈论过的两位总统，特朗普，还有尼克松，他们都把自己塑造为普通人、普通美国人、方下巴、行事公正的小人物的捍卫者。尼克松经常谈到小人物对抗华尔街、纽约、新英格兰以及其他地方那些傲慢的自大狂。
it. So actually, that sense of it being style rather than policy, I think is something they completely have in common, the two systems. Yeah, and I think that what's interesting about Trump is, and it so often doesn't come across just in the press reports, is that he's actually quite funny and quite a lot of what he says, so the comments about McCain, the classic example, are shocking, but a kind of designed to appeal to people who find the kind of traditional norms a bit stuffy, a bit boring. And that, again, is very, very Roman, because the kind of people who identify with the traditional ideals of the Roman Republic, I mean, they call themselves the Boni, the good people, the good guys. And set against them, there are people who are called populares, people who appeal to the people. So, I mean, you could translate that as populists. And that sense
所以实际上，那种关乎风格而非政策的感觉，我认为是这两个系统完全共同拥有的东西。是的，而且我认为特朗普有趣的地方在于，新闻报道中往往无法体现出来的是，他其实相当风趣，他所说的很多话——比如关于麦凯恩的评论就是一个经典例子——虽然令人震惊，但旨在吸引那些觉得传统规范有点古板、有点无聊的人。而这再次非常非常罗马化，因为那些认同罗马共和国传统理想的人——我的意思是，他们自称为“精英”（Boni），也就是好人、好家伙。与他们对立的，是被称为“平民派”（populares）的人，即那些吸引民众的人。所以，我的意思是，你可以把它翻译成民粹主义者。
that to be a populist is somehow underhand is absolutely what the Boni, the good guys, are about in Roman politics. And I think that's, that's very much been a trend in, in, in American politics as well. Hillary Clinton was, was the sort of Bonnie par excellence, wasn't she? I mean, she was a sort of, sort of, people often talked about her sort of school mistracy, is that a word? School mistracy side. The fact that she's, you know, she's always, you know, Miss Goody Two Shoes. And Donald Trump was the sort of raucous boy at the back of the class who's stirring up all the others against her. Yeah, well, but also all the presidential you know Miss Goody Two-Shoes and Donald Trump was the sort of raucous boy at the back of the class who's stirring up all the others against her. Yeah well but also all the presidential candidates I mean even Nixon have kind of served their time in the traditional way so they've they've they've
而那种认为民粹主义者某种程度上是卑鄙的感觉，正是罗马政治中“精英”们所代表的。我认为这在很大程度上也是美国政治中的一种趋势。希拉里·克林顿就是那种“精英”的典范，对吧？我的意思是，她是一种，人们经常谈论她的那种“女校校长”般的——这是一个词吗？——“女校校长”的一面。事实上，她总是，你知道的，是个“好女孩”。而唐纳德·特朗普则是后排那个吵吵闹闹、煽动其他人对抗她的坏小子。是的，不过所有的总统候选人——
gone up what the Romans would call the cursus honorum the kind of the the greasy pole they've they've served their time in politics they or they've served in the military or whatever or they academics or whatever. Trump didn't. I mean, Trump came from a background essentially in entertainment, and that's how he's governed. I mean, it wasn't that he brought the methodology of entertainment to politics. He turned politics into a form of entertainment. And that, again, was something that was kind of a part of Roman life. There were political figures who used gladiatorial entertainments, whatever, as a way of winning popular support. And they would mock the traditions that more conventional political figures upheld. So I wanted to talk to you about that, Tom, because I think you and I have talked about this in other contexts about Roman emperors. So,
我的意思是，即使是尼克松，也都是以传统方式熬过资历的，所以他们走完了罗马人所说的“荣誉阶梯”（cursus honorum），也就是那种升迁的滑竿，他们在政界熬过资历，或者他们在军队服役过，或者诸如此类，或者他们是学者之类的。特朗普没有。我的意思是，特朗普的背景基本上是娱乐业，而他也是这样执政的。我的意思是，并不是说他把娱乐的方法论带到了政治中。他是把政治变成了一种娱乐形式。而这再次也是罗马生活的一部分。有一些政治人物利用角斗士娱乐等作为赢得民众支持的方式。他们会嘲笑更传统的政治人物所坚守的传统。所以我想跟你聊聊这个，汤姆，因为我觉得你和我曾在其他语境下谈论过罗马皇帝。所以，
you know, Trump is an exceedingly rich man. He's actually somebody who, in many ways, you know, people raise their eyebrows that he's the champion of the common man. But in Rome, there were obviously early emperors who, you know, steeped in wealth and privilege, but who had enormous success in doing exactly what you've talked about, staging gladiatorial games, pandering to the mob. People like, I guess, Caligula, Nero, are we talking about those kind of emperors? All Roman politicians were incredibly rich. I mean, you had to be. It was, again, very like American politics politics you just couldn't get anywhere without basically being very rich um so that that that wasn't really the issue the issue was yeah was essentially whether you were were you making a pitch to what the common guy thought or were you
你知道，特朗普是一个极其富有的人。实际上，他在很多方面，你知道的，人们会对他是普通人的捍卫者这一点感到惊掉下巴。但在罗马，显然有早期的皇帝，你知道的，沉浸在财富和特权中，但在做你刚才谈到的事情时取得了巨大的成功——举办角斗士比赛，迎合暴民。像卡利古拉、尼禄这样的人，我们是在讨论那种皇帝吗？所有的罗马政治家都极其富有。我的意思是，你必须如此。这再次非常类似于美国政治，你如果不非常有钱，基本上就哪儿也去不了，所以那其实并不是问题所在。问题在于，本质上是，你是在迎合普通人的想法，还是在
standing sternly for for the traditional values so compare i mean all comparisons obviously like this are are incredibly stretched But I think not entirely so with American Rome, simply because the American Republic did found itself on the kind of model of the Roman Republic. And I think you do get this, this kind of dynamic. So Trump compares, well, I mean, you say he's very rich, is he? I mean, that's one of the issues. And I'm sure, you know, one of the reasons why he's so desperate to cling on to the presidency is actually a kind of interesting parallel with with Julius Caesar, because Caesar constantly flirted with bankruptcy. He speculated to accumulate. And in doing that, he brushed very, very heavily against the law. So the threat for Caesar was always that his enemies would prosecute him and bring him to trial.
坚定地捍卫传统价值观？所以比较——我的意思是，所有这样的比较显然都非常牵强。但我认为对于美国和罗马来说并非完全如此，仅仅是因为美国共和国确实建立在罗马共和国的模式之上。而且我认为你确实能看到这种动态。所以特朗普比较——好吧，我的意思是，你说他很有财富，是吗？我的意思是，这是问题之一。而且我确信，你知道，他拼命想要抓住总统职位不放的原因之一，实际上与尤利乌斯·凯撒有一个非常有趣的相似之处，因为凯撒经常在破产边缘试探。他为了积累而进行投机。在这样做的过程中，他非常非常严重地触犯了法律。所以对凯撒来说，威胁始终是他的敌人会起诉他并把他送上法庭。
And one of the reasons, ultimately, we know we talked about civil wars in a previous episode, but one of the reasons why Caesar ends up crossing the Rubicon and involving Rome in a civil war is that he gets cornered by his enemies. His enemies want to prosecute him. Caesar can't be prosecuted while he holds an official rank in the Republic. So he's the governor of Gaul, so he can't be prosecuted. The moment he lays that governorship down and becomes a private citizen, then he can be prosecuted. So the issue on the Rubicon is that Caesar wants to go seamlessly from being governor of Gaul to being consul so that he doesn't run the risk of prosecution. And basically, Trump is in a kind of analogous situation. And I'm sure that if, like CZ, he had battle-hardened
最终的原因之一——我们知道我们在前一集里谈论过内战——但凯撒最终越过卢比孔河并让罗马卷入内战的原因之一是他被敌人逼入了绝境。他的敌人想要起诉他。凯撒在共和国拥有官方职务期间是不能被起诉的。所以他是高卢总督，所以他不能被起诉。他卸任总督并成为普通公民的那一刻，他就可以被起诉了。所以在卢比孔河上的问题是，凯撒想要无缝地从高卢总督过渡为执政官，这样他就不会冒被起诉的风险。基本上，特朗普处於一种类似的情况。而且我确信，如果像凯撒那样，他身后有百战百胜的
legions behind him, he absolutely wouldn't surrender the presidency. I mean, he wouldn't hesitate to cross the Rubicon. But what current events show is that actually, he doesn't have the Republican Party behind him. No, no. I mean, did you see no i mean did you see that extraordinary did you see that press conference at the garden center that i think is the that's my favorite thing that's ever happened did you see that um he tried to book the four seasons so yesterday he tried to book the four seasons hotel in philadelphia for rudy giuliani to unveil all his sort of ballot rigging claims but they they booked the wrong place they booked a place called four seasons total landscaping inping in suburban Philadelphia,
军团支持，他绝对不会交出总统权力的。我的意思是，他绝不会犹豫越过卢比孔河。但时事表明，实际上，他并没有共和党人在背后支持他。不，不。我的意思是，你看到了吗？不，我的意思是，你看到了那个非同寻常的——你看到了在那个园艺中心举行的记者招待会吗？我认为那是发生过的我最喜欢的事情。你看到了吗？他试图预订四季酒店——所以昨天他试图为鲁迪·朱利安尼预订费城的四季酒店，以便揭露他关于舞弊选票的所有声称，但他们订错了地方，他们订了一个叫做“四季全景景观园林”（Four Seasons Total landscaping）的地方，位于费城郊区，
which is between a sex shop and a crematorium. And Giuliani was there giving the press conference at the very moment that the networks called the election for Trump. So it's this extraordinarily humiliating way to, as people have said, you know, he started his political career coming down a golden escalator and he ended it in the car park of a philadelphia garden center right so that's very much not standing on the banks of the river con with legion behind you
介于一家性用品商店和火葬场之间。而朱利安尼就在那里举行记者招待会，恰好就在各大电视网宣布特朗普赢得大选的那个时刻。所以这是一种极其耻辱的方式，正如人们所说的那样，你知道的，他乘着金色扶梯开始了政治生涯，而他却在费城的一个园艺中心停车场结束了政治生涯。没错，这绝对不是站在卢比孔河岸边，身后带着军团，
sat with a god about to blow on a trumpet and summon you to glory but what about these characters like um like the neros and the the caligulas you know these people who you can absolutely imagine doing the roman equivalent of tweeting how great they are and mocking their opponents. I mean, the mocking your opponents, which Trump does, that's quite a Roman thing, isn't it? Yes. So wholesale abuse of your opponents is very much a Roman thing. And I think that, so Augustus, who's the first emperor, his genius is to keep these two traditions, the tradition of the Boni and the tradition of the Populares, kind of in balance. He is able to play at both of them. Tiberius is very much a traditionalist. He's very much a kind of John McCain figure. Caligula, who succeeds him, his genius is to discover that you can root your power in the popularist tradition, that you can become very, very popular by essentially... Caligula kind of, you know, he roars around town with a chariot drawn by kind of hundreds of horses.
旁边坐着一个准备吹号召唤你走向荣耀的神。但是像尼禄和卡利古拉这样的人物呢，你知道的，你可以完全想象这些人会做罗马版的发推特吹嘘自己有多伟大并嘲笑他们的对手。我的意思是，嘲笑你的对手——特朗普就是这么做的——这挺罗马化的，不是吗？是的。所以对对手进行全面的人身攻击非常具有罗马特色。而且我认为，奥古斯都作为第一位皇帝，他的天才之处在于能够保持这两种传统——“精英”传统和“平民”传统的平衡。他能够两边都玩得转。提比略非常传统。他非常像一个约翰·麦凯恩式的人物。继承他的卡利古拉，他的天才之处在于发现你可以将自己的权力根植于平民派传统中，你可以通过基本上……卡利古拉可以说是……卡利古拉驾驶着由数百匹马拉着的战车在城里呼啸而过。
This is absolutely the equivalent of having, you know, gold... Stretch limo. ...everywhere in Europe. Yeah, stretch limos and things like that. So it kind of appeals to people. I mean, Kligler understands that. And he understands that he can win enormous popularity by ripping the piss out of the traditional way of doing things, out of kind of humiliating senators,
这绝对相当于在欧洲到处都有黄金……加长豪华轿车。……到处都是。是的，加长豪华轿车之类的东西。所以这很吸引人。我的意思是，卡利古拉明白这一点。他明白，通过取笑传统的行事方式、羞辱参议员，
out of mocking them, out of threatening them, out of sometimes killing them. So that's why he makes... And it turns out to be a source of great popularity for him. So that's why he makes his horse a consul, right? Or says he's going to make his horse a consul? Because he wants to mock the institution. So he never makes his horse a consul,
嘲笑他们、威胁他们、有时甚至杀死他们，他能够赢得巨大的声望。所以这就是为什么他让……事实证明这为他带来了巨大的声望。所以这就是为什么他让他的马当执政官，对吧？或者说他要让他的马当执政官？因为他想嘲弄这个体制。所以他从来没有真的让他的马当执政官，
but it's a joke because he's essentially saying to senators, I have so much power that if I want to, I could make my horse a consul. But then, of course, it's the senators who write the history. It's kind of the equivalent of the New York Times who write the history. And so Caligula gets condemned after he gets assassinated, not by senators, but by the Praetorians, because that's the key thing. Don't piss off your base like that. Very foolish to mock people who have swords.
但这只是个笑话，因为他本质上是在对参议员们说：我有这么大的权力，如果我想的话，我完全可以让我的马当执政官。但当然，写历史的是参议员们。这有点相当于《纽约时报》在写历史。所以卡利古拉在被刺杀后遭到了谴责，不是由参议员们发起的，而是由近卫军发起的，因为这才是关键所在。千万别那样惹恼你的底线。去嘲笑那些手握刀剑的人是非常愚蠢的。
Yeah. So Caligula can't help. I mean, he can't help mocking people. And so he mocks a commander in the Praetorian Guard, which is a fatal mistake. And so that's what dooms him. But after Caligula's death, his jokes get rewritten to demonstrate that he was insane. And I think there's a sense in which that's happened with Trump as well, that the things that he said as jokes get rewritten to illustrate he's mad or a dictator or whatever.
是的。所以卡利古拉忍不住。我的意思是，他忍不住要嘲笑别人。于是他嘲笑了一位禁卫军指挥官，这是一个致命的错误。这就是他走向毁灭的原因。但在卡利古拉死后，他的笑话被重新编造，以证明他是个疯子。我认为特朗普身上也发生了类似的事情，他作为笑话所说的话被重新诠释，以说明他疯了、是个独裁者或者别的什么。
Yeah. And, you know, that's the fate of losers. Trump is a loser. Yes, I suppose that's true, isn't it? And what about Nero? So is Nero also quite Trumpian? I think he is, isn't he? I mean, Nero's got, am I right, Nero's fat as well, wasn't he?
是的。而且，你知道，那是失败者的命运。特朗普就是个失败者。是的，我想这是真的，对吧？那尼禄呢？所以尼禄也很“特朗普化”吗？我想他是的，对吧？我的意思是，尼禄，我没记错的话，尼禄也很胖，不是吗？
He was a very ginormous fellow. Yes, yes. Am I right? Nero was fat as well, wasn't he? He was a ginormous fellow. Yes. Well, so you get this kind of swing in Roman politics where a traditionalist is succeeded by a popularist, is succeeded by a traditionalist. So after Caligula, you get Claudius, who's an antiquarian, very interested in Roman tradition. And then you get Nero, who is absolutely a popularist to the degree that he, you know, he does equivalent, you know, he plays the lyre in public. He races chariots at the Olympics, he appears on the stage. And this would be the equivalent of Trump, I guess, kind of headlining Glastonbury, awarding himself an Oscar, sweeping the board at the Oscars. But I mean, that's, Trump did that first, right, with The Apprentice and all that? Absolutely.
他是一个非常庞大的家伙。是的，是的。我没记错吧？尼禄也很胖，不是吗？他是一个庞大的家伙。是的。嗯，所以在罗马政治中会出现这样一种摇摆，即传统主义者之后是民粹主义者，民粹主义者之后又是传统主义者。所以在卡利古拉之后，你迎来了克劳狄乌斯，他是一个古物研究者，对罗马传统非常感兴趣。然后你迎来了尼禄，他绝对是一个民粹主义者，甚至到了这样的程度：你知道的，他做类似的事情，你知道的，他在公众面前弹奏里拉琴。他在奥运会上赛车，他登台表演。这相当于特朗普，我猜，比如在格拉斯顿伯里音乐节上压轴演出，给自己颁发奥斯卡奖，在奥斯卡上横扫所有奖项。但我的意思是，特朗普最先做到了这一点，对吧，通过《学徒》之类节目？绝对的。
And people like it and people are amused by it. And when Nero dies, although all the kind of New York Times equivalents are ecstatic about it, there are lots of people who are left bereft and flowers are laid on his grave.
人们喜欢它，人们觉得很有趣。当尼禄死后，尽管所有《纽约时报》式的媒体都欣喜若狂，但仍有许多人感到若有所失，并在他的墓前献上鲜花。
And there are even people who kind of pop up in Greece pretending to be Nero. And obviously there's no capital in pretending to be Nero if there isn't a kind of market for Nero. Yeah. And in a weird way, that's actually clearly going to happen in America, right? That people will try, there will now be a fight, assuming that Donald Trump is probably too old to run again in 2024. There will be a fight. And assuming he doesn't go to prison. Yes. But even if he does, there will be a fight to inherit
甚至还有人跑到希腊假装自己是尼禄。很显然，如果没有对尼禄的市场，假装尼禄也就没有任何价值。是的。从某种奇怪的角度来看，这显然也会在美国发生，对吧？人们会尝试，现在将展开一场争夺战，假设唐纳德·特朗普在2024年可能已经太老而无法再次参选。将会有一场争夺战。假设他没有进监狱。是的。但即使他进了监狱，也会有一场争夺……的战斗
his mantle, to be the new Donald Trump, to appeal to that sort of popularised tradition, won't it? Don't you think? Yeah, and I guess that would be a difference between Trump and Nixon, is that no one wanted to be the new Nixon. No, although, although, here's the interesting thing that, you know, Nixon himself was discredited. I mean, I know he did his interviews with David Frost, and he spoke at the Oxford Union, he tried to sort of transform himself into a statesman and sage, but he never quite pulled it off. But Nixon's politics endured. So Nixon, I think a lot of American political historians would say, you know, Nixon is the man who really invents and perfects the appeal to the little guy as opposed to the establishment. So he turns... So who are his heirs? So his heirs, I mean, Reagan, to some extent, Reagan, you know, is also, you know, I'm an
他的衣钵，成为新的唐纳德·特朗普，吸引那种民粹主义传统，不是吗？你不觉得吗？是的，我想这可能是特朗普和尼禄……哦不，特朗普和尼克松之间的一个区别，那就是没有人想成为新的尼克松。不，虽然，虽然，这里有趣的是，尼克松本人名誉扫地。我的意思是，我知道他接受了大卫·弗罗斯特的采访，他在牛津辩论社发言，他试图把自己塑造为一个政治家和智者，但他从未完全成功。然而尼克松的政治理念延续了下来。所以尼克松，我想很多美国政治史学家会说，你知道，尼克松才是真正发明并完善了呼吁普通人而非建制派的人。所以他把……那么他的继承人是谁呢？所以他的继承人，我的意思是，里根，在某种程度上，里根，你知道，也是，你知道，我是个
ordinary person. I'm not a stuck up snob. I'm not, you know, Reagan's whole pitch was that I am an ordinary middle American. You know, I happen to have been in Hollywood and all the rest of it. But I speak for, you know, Main Street America. And that's obviously, you know, Trump's is a more aggressive form of that appeal. But it's a world away from the Republican appeal in the mid 20th century, or the early 20th century, the Republican Party was clearly a much more sort of staid and elitist party than it became under from Nixon onwards. So Nixon at school, at college rather, he'd founded a society called the Orthogonians, the square shooters. And they were, you know, it was all about we are not the privileged people on campus. We are the ordinary people. We are the kind of little guys. We poke fun at our betters.
普通人。我不是一个高傲的势利小人。我不是，你知道，里根的全部调调就是我是一个普通的中产美国人。你知道，我恰好在好莱坞待过以及诸如此类的事情。但我代表的是，你知道，美国的主流大街。这显然，你知道，特朗普是这种诉求的一种更具攻击性的形式。但这与20世纪中叶或20世纪初共和党人的诉求有着天壤之别，早期的共和党人显然是一个比从尼克松时代开始后要循规蹈矩、精英主义得多的政党。所以在尼克松上学时，或者说上大学时，他创立了一个名为“正交主义者”（Orthogonians）的社团，也就是那些实干家。他们是，你知道，这完全是关于我们不是校园里的特权阶层。我们是普通人。我们是那种小人物。我们取笑我们的上级。
We poke fun at the elite. And that in that society that Nixon founded when he was a student, you can see the kind of contours of Republican Party politics right now, that we champion, you know, the small town, the rural village, against the big cities, the highly educated people, you know, all of that kind of thing. And I think that thing, that Nixon created that, and that will endure. And so commentators who know vastly more about American politics than I do are saying that Trump has kind of created a new constituency. Yeah. Unexpected degree of support from minority voters. And perhaps that's something that a future Republican candidate will be able to draw on. Yes. But I wonder, what do you think about the way in which he's behaved over the past few days, and presumably will be behaving over the months that he has left in the White House?
我们取笑精英阶层。在尼克松还是个学生时创立的那个社团里，你可以看到现在共和党政治的轮廓，我们捍卫小城镇、乡村来对抗大城市、受过高等教育的人，你知道，诸如此类的事情。我认为那件事，尼克松创造了这一点，而且这将会延续下去。因此，那些比我更了解美国政治的评论员们都在说，特朗普开辟了一种新的选民群体。是的。少数族裔选民给予了意料之外的支持。或许这正是未来共和党候选人可以借鉴的东西。是的。不过我在想，你如何看待他在过去几天里的表现，以及可以想见他在白宫剩下的几个月里会有的表现？
How damaging do you think that it will be to the fabric of American democracy? And is it something that future candidates, I guess Democrat as well as Republican, might kind of draw lessons from? Or will it be remembered as a kind of embarrassing incident like the Nixon? I think it will probably be the latter, actually. So before this all happened, I mean, a lot of people,
你认为这会对美国民主的根基造成多大的破坏？这是否会成为未来候选人（我猜民主党和共和党都是如此）可能会从中汲取教训的事情？还是会被记住为一个类似尼克松那样的尴尬事件？我想实际上可能后者居多。所以在这这一切发生之前，我的意思是，很多人，
and myself included, thought this could be really damaging and toxic for American politics, that it could actually corrode the pluralism that democracy depends on, which is basically, as you know, that if you lose, you walk away and your opponents don't then kill you or put you in jail or something, because they know that when they lose, you won't do, you know, you'll treat them with respect as well. And I think a lot of people feared that this would be a complete disaster and that, you know, there'd be riots on the streets and all the rest of it. But actually what's happened mean he's been ridiculed hasn't he the republican media have
包括我在内，都认为这可能会对美国政治造成真正的破坏和毒害，它实际上可能会侵蚀民主所依赖的多元主义，也就是基本上，如你所知，如果你输了，你就走人，而你的对手不会因此杀死你或把你关进监狱什么的，因为他们知道当他们输了时，你也不会，你知道，你也会尊重他们。我想很多人曾担心这会是一场彻底的灾难，你知道的，街头会发生骚乱之类的。但实际上发生的情况是，他被嘲笑了，对吧，共和党媒体已经
largely abandoned him fox news the new york post and so on the republican party have not come out in in support of him and actually i think it will be remembered as a a classic sort of tragicomic trump episode that you know he he he he left office in this ridiculous, shambolic, actually slightly pitiful way. And actually his legacy, if he had sort of grumpily conceded, which is the alternative, I mean, it's obviously impossible to imagine him graciously conceding, but if he'd kind of reluctantly and rather bitterly conceded,
在很大程度上抛弃了他，福克斯新闻、《纽约邮报》等等，共和党人并没有站出来支持他。实际上我认为这将被铭记为一个经典的悲喜剧式的特朗普插曲，你知道的，他以这种荒谬的、混乱的、甚至有点可怜的方式离开了白宫。实际上，如果他当时是气呼呼地承认失败，也就是另一种选择——我的意思是，显然不可能想象他会风度翩翩地认输，但如果他是带着勉强和相当痛苦的心情承认失败的话，
then, you know, I think his legacy would be, well, it would be less tarnished than it is right now. Don't you? And what if, what if after he's, if he ever gets out of the White House, they drag him out? I mean, what if he gets prosecuted? What if he gets convicted? What if he gets, goes to prison? What kind of impact would that have? Well, first of all, I don't think he will go to prison. I mean, Donald Trump is an expert. If there's one thing he knows a lot about, it's litigation. And I think he and his lawyers will find ways to prolong any trial,
那么，你知道，我认为他的政治遗产将，嗯，会比现在少一些玷污。你不这么认为吗？如果，如果在被……如果他真的走出了白宫，他们把他拖出来呢？我的意思是，如果他被起诉了呢？如果他被定罪了呢？如果他进监狱了呢？那会产生什么样的影响？好吧，首先，我不认为他会进监狱。我的意思是，唐纳德·特朗普是个专家。如果有一件事他非常了解，那就是诉讼。我想他和他的律师会找到方法来拖延任何审判，
you know, and any case. There'll be appeals and appeals. I also don't actually think there's that much appetite for... I think a lot of Americans just for, and I think people, a lot of Americans just want the soap opera to end, rather like they did with Nixon. So Nixon was pardoned by successor Gerald Ford, basically because they thought, yeah, he is clearly guilty of crimes, but we just want to put this thing to bed now. You know, we don't want it hanging over us for the next five years. And I think that's what people feel about Trump. The thing is, he doesn't make a very persuasive martyr, does he? I mean, he's not,
你知道，还有任何案件。会有不断地上诉。而且实际上我也认为没有那么大的胃口……我认为许多美国人只是为了，而且我认为人们，许多美国人只是希望这场肥皂剧结束，就像他们对尼克松做的那样。所以尼克松被他的继任者杰拉尔德·福特赦免了，基本上是因为他们认为，是的，他显然犯了罪，但我们现在只想把这件事搁置起来。你知道，我们不希望它在未来五年里一直悬在我们头上。我想这就是人们对特朗普的看法。问题是，他当不了一个很有说服力的烈士，不是吗？我的意思是，他不是，
he's, that's not really in his sort of skill set, playing the victim. That's something that Trump hates to do, because he hates losers. Yeah. So I don't really, I think he will go and sulk in Trump Tower, and tweet for the rest of his days. And he'll try to have an influence over the future of the Republican Party. So he will become the Edward Heath of his days. And he'll try to have an influence over the future of the Republican Party. So he will become the Edward Heath of American history. That is a very- Apologies there to any American listeners to the podcast. I really, nobody enjoys an Edward Heath analogy more than I do.
他，那不是他的强项，扮演受害者。那是特朗普最讨厌做的事，因为他讨厌失败者。是的。所以我真的认为，他会去特朗普大厦生闷气，并在余生里发推特。他会试图对共和党未来产生影响。所以他将成为他那个时代的爱德华·希思。他会试图对共和党未来产生影响。所以他将成为美国历史上的爱德华·希思。那是一个非常——向播客的任何美国听众道歉。真的，没有人比我更享受一个爱德华·希思的比喻了。
Yes, he'll be holed up in the American equivalent of Salisbury playing his piano, or in his case, playing a lot of golf. Well, I think that is a perfect note on which to end. We'll finish with the words of, for now, President Donald J. Trump, who tweeted last night in capital letters, I won this election by a lot. And this despite Joe Biden receiving around five million more votes. Bye from us. See you next time.
是的，他将隐居在美国版的索尔兹伯里弹钢琴，或者对他而言，打很多高尔夫球。好吧，我认为这是一个完美的结束语。我们将以现在依然是唐纳德·J·特朗普总统的话来结束，他昨晚用大写字母发推特说：“我以巨大优势赢得了这次大选。”尽管乔·拜登多获得了大约五百万张选票。我们跟大家说再见。下次见。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听独家节目、提前访问、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。